okay welcome everyone and a nice robust
turnout today and it's always a good
today is our regular Thursday conference
and sometimes we have various student
presentations and one of the steps along
the way to the PhD degree is a symposium
where a student kind of gives the
background and sets the stage for their
dissertation work and so we're going to
hear that today from Eric loon who's a
PhD candidate in our program in the BCB
tract Eric's a graduate of University of
Oklahoma and received dual bachelor's
degrees in math and biochemistry and
while he was there he helped assemble
the genome of the anopheles gambiae a
mosquito which is carrier of the malaria
parasite he also worked in a lab
studying weakly electric fish in trying
to sequence a potassium channel protein
he became interested in biomedical
informatics when learning about a risk
assessment making use of a patient
wellness portal that's bioinformatics
but that's great it is it very much is
some days patients will look up their
genome and their patient portal anyways
he also learned about the health
information exchange network that was
being developed in Oklahoma and during
his time here he's transitioned to
learning about bacteria in your gut and
how it influences health which you
actually heard about yesterday - the
microbiome and is he's interested in
applying computational methods to
understand these interactions he's also
well-prepared for it because he's one of
the few BCB students who has taken BMI
510 anyway so I will
I won't delay any further Eric's talk
anyway okay
right hi everyone thanks for coming to
my talk so today I'll be talking as bill
said about the area of research that I'd
like to go into and what is called is
the microbiota gut brain access and
specifically I'm interested in its
connection with mental health and so
I'll start off talking a little bit
about some history on each of these
three components and how they eventually
converge into being studied together and
then I'll go into some case studies in
which they were actually stayed together
and then go off on to talking about some
potential areas in which I could go in
to see
okay okay so just be uh just briefly on
the microbial I'll get to it in more
detail in just a bit but for now I was
just likely to know that the microbial
is just a collection of microorganisms
that exist in and on you as ghosts as
that might sound but they are the
collection of the microbes in your body
so what I like to do is propose a
question for you to think about during
my presentation so the microbial or
specifically the ones in your gut can
they influence your your brain and even
your behavior and even if they can't
have some sort of influence how can
these three characters the the gut the
bacteria in your gut and also your brain
how can they even talk to each other or
have some sort of relationship kind of
like in this cartoon behind me so other
than three let's start with the brain
and specifically in mental health and so
there are variety of mental health
disorders and two of which I want to
focus on our depression and anxiety and
so both of these are quite prevalent
globally and so according to the World
Health Organization over 300 people or
over 300 million people on the world
suffer from depression in terms of the
anxiety in the u.s. it's estimated about
18% of the adult population as anxiety
knowing or is there's a societal burden
that there's also a financial burden
with the high prevalence of that so
there's some estimates that say for
anxiety in the u.s. it costs about forty
two billion and depression costs upwards
around two hundred and ten billion a
year
so with these these numbers are quite
snaring and make it important or a
motivation to study these sort of
diseases
so yeah with these staggering numbers of
its prevalence and also these numbers
show the high prevalence and the
financial burden of these disease not to
mention the also possible personal and
social impertinence that we might face
at a lifetimes as well so all of which
can contribute to why we might want to
study depression and anxiety
so we star in the brain and now let's
incorporate the gut and so people have
been saying the brain and the gut
together as early as ancient Greeks and
so one example is this guy over here
called Galen of Pergamon and so he was a
physician a philosopher and surgeon and
he was well known for being an expert in
human anatomy and so one thing he
observed is a physical connection
between the gut and your brain in terms
of the nerves being innovated throughout
your gut and also various other organs
fast forward to the late 1800s we come
to the development of more conceptual or
a theoretical framework to think about
the connection between the gut and the
brain and so to people I went highlights
are these men over here and we have Carl
Langham who is a Danish physician and we
have William James an American physician
and so surprising love surprisingly
enough they were actually able to
independently think of a theory of
emotion and which is now known as the
james-lange theory of emotion and
emotion being anywhere something like
love or fear anger and so what this
theory says is that we feel emotion as
our brains reaction to initial
physiological responses so say I guess
more gut related
phenomenon is like say you're in love
and a typical thing they feel is you
know butterflies in your stomach so what
the theory would say is that you would
first have some gut reaction and then
your brain would perceive that and then
you would feel this emotion of love so
even though there are more modern
theories of emotion or the connection
between your brain and other organs this
simulaid the groundwork for a lot of
form that exists today so years go by
and researchers continue to dive into
this interaction between we've got brain
and big gut and so they discovered this
bi-directional signaling or
communication that the brain and gut
have and so bright directional means
that there's a top-down signaling from
the gut to the brain and also a
bottom-up signaling from the gut to the
brain all right yeah so in the next few
slides I like to just highlight briefly
those directions independently so from
more top-down view going from the brain
to the gut two major mechanisms in which
the brain can influence the gut or the
autonomic nervous system and the HPA
axis and so with the focusing on the
autonomic nervous system this nervous
system is involved in controlling
involuntary actions of your internal
organs such as your heart being or
digestion and so even within this the
autonomic nervous system there are two
pieces to it the sympathetic nervous
system and the parasympathetic nervous
system the sympathetic nervous system is
related to what is known as the
fight-or-flight response or something
that if you're stressed your body will
react in that way additionally there's a
parasympathetic nervous system is
associated with what's called the rest
and digest response so there are your
organs will do different things in these
different states
going into the HPA axis which is stands
for the hypothalamus pituitary adrenal
axis and so what this axis is
responsible for is our body's ability to
control and respond to stress and so how
this one might be related to how
influences to gut is that these three
organs might release some sort of
molecules which will then pick it back
on the autonomic nervous system and send
certain signals down to pick up I'm
going the opposite way going from the
breath they're going from the gut to the
brain we have three major mechanisms for
this as well we have a more immune
response and endocrine response and a
mechanical or neural response as well so
immune response in our gut is another
barrier between the outside world and
our internal organs so you can imagine
the amount of immune cells that might
need to be there to protect from any
pathogens that might enter our body and
so the mean so there might be able to
interact and send signals back up to the
brain
additionally endocrine molecules such as
serotonin and histamine might be
generating the gut which also will
affect the brain as well and lastly
there could be a mechanical feedback
from just your digestive tract trying to
get rid of certain foods and also yeah
and also the the foods that are there to
move it along so that kind of feedback
loop will also get to your brain so now
we come to a point where all three you
you include now the the microbiota in
there and we get the microbiota gut
brain access and so this addition or
this discovery all three together as
main impact and you could even say this
in a paradigm shift in turn fields like
neuroscience and psychiatry the reason
being is that even without the
microbiome
those disciplines have long ignored or
haven't really taken account even the
long amount of research that has been
happening in the gut and brain
connections I just mentioned the four
and so now with advent of new technology
we can now understand or at least
measure some of the bacteria in our gut
and back has an additional piece that
can be added to the mix so this allows a
way for you to for at least further
analyze or understand these highly
complex diseases and neurological
disorders and so so much momentum has
been gained that even some funding or
some organizations worldwide has become
interested in this topic such as na NIH
in the US and also in the EU
so I mentioned briefly about the microbe
and here I've come to talk about it
again
so the gut microbiota is agree there the
trillions of bacteria that lives inside
of your gut and so to large groups of
them remember briefly in our taxonomy
classification if we look at the genus
level which is pretty low the largest
group is called the Bacteroides and then
if you go a little bit higher up in the
taxonomy and looking at the phylum level
the most that we have are the thermic
use so in my talk I'll be focusing on
the gut microbiota interaction with the
brain specifically but just in general a
little more information about the gut
microbiota is also implicated and
various other diseases as well
such as obesity and diabetes and several
other gastrointestinal disorders as well
so there's been a thought that the
connection between your gut microbiota
and these diseases is because of some
imbalance or some differences and
changes in your gut also called or what
people call dysbiosis in your microbio
that may
have some influence on this these
diseases in some way so now I'd like to
switch gears into talking a little bit
about the some case studies that involve
all three the microbiota the gut and the
brain into studying how they're related
to some mental or specifically anxiety
and depression they'll talk about
initial study and which trying to leak
link depression anxiety with the risk of
a gut related disease then I'll go into
some behavioral experiments in rats and
mice and how how they decided to infer
suggest that microbiome might be
involved in anxiety and then I'll end
with a another case study and focusing
on depression in humans as well so this
far off there's this one study it was
conducted because in 2000 there is a
unfortunate contamination of some
drinking water in a Canadian Canadian
town and which led to a an outbreak of
pathogenic ecoli and with this ecoli
it's spread it started to spread
essentially the stomach flu around and
which had serious consequences and so at
the time people have known that having
the stomach flu is a risk factor for
developing something called irritable
bowel syndrome or IBS for short and so
at the time the pathogenesis of IBS was
poorly understood so what these
researchers wanted to do is take this
opportunity to study this prospectively
and so they did so following these
individuals in this town for a total of
eight years and so just to show that
there is a link or some sort of
association between Zelnick flu and IBS
here's a plot showing the association
between the individuals
who have either self-reported that they
have the stomach flu or that have been
clinically diagnosed in the more darker
bars and then you have unexposed
controls from the contaminated water and
the white bars down here so as you can
see the the effect of having the stomach
flu increases your prevalence of IBS and
so again I mentioned that IBS at the
time people didn't understand the
pathology quite so well and so they took
this opportunity to then try to find
some risk factors for IBS and so some
risk factors that they decide to look at
where aged female or gender I mean
anxiety and then certain other acute
illnesses or features of acute illnesses
and so what they did is a multiple
logistic regression and the results of
that analysis are shown in this table I
don't want you to take in this table
just yet but the results of this is
certain odds ratios for each of these
variables and an odds ratio generally is
a quantification of the strength between
these variables and some other variable
interests in this case it's the
incidence of IBS and so the ones I want
to focus on here is prior anxiety and
depression and so in each of their years
they looked at they were in this model
and try to see if there's some
association and so in the early years
there wasn't any significance for prior
depression to be a risk factor for IBS
but then in 2008 their model showed that
there is a statistical significance
between the two and so this implies or
suggests that there might be some
connection between depression or is a
mental health issue and gut related
issues
and so for the next couple case studies
they move to more animal models for
studying anxiety and so two of the tests
I want to highlight here are called the
step-down test and the light-dark box
test and so for the step-down test you
have a box and then you have an elevated
platform in the middle and so what you
do is you'll put the animal on top of
that I guess pedestal or platform and
then you'll wait to see how long it
would take for the animal to step down
from that platform and so this is a
measure of anxiety because if you're in
a new area you might not want to explore
it as much so the more anxious animals
might just stay on there a little bit
longer and take quite a bit of time to
get down while the more explorative ones
and less anxious one animals might be
quicker to come down and explore the
area the summary test is the light dark
box test in which you have two
compartments a more lit area and a
darker area and again this is a test for
anxiety in which less anxious mice or
animals will want to explore and be in
the lit area while the more anxious ones
will stay in the darker areas as well so
you can measure the time in which
they're in the light Eretz as a
indication of how anxious certain animal
is and so again so there's a study that
made use of these two tests and so what
they wanted to do is try to look at the
influence of the microbiota and certain
behavioral and brains of brain chemistry
changes so here they have a model in
which they have control mice which is
just a normal developing mice with all
its microbes and then you have the same
kind of mice but then they subjected
them to a cocktail of antibiotics or
anti microbials for a whole week to try
to really disrupt all the bacteria that
they might have in their gut system
and so then they subject them to these
anxiety tests and so on the left you can
see the results from their step-down
test and so the controls they took about
a little over 200 seconds to walk down
from that platform however the
antibiotic treatment treated mice they
took only a hundred seconds to get down
so this is just that they're less
anxious and they are able to explore
order they would want to explore a
little bit more again suggesting maybe
that the microbiota might have some
influence on anxiety generally in the
the box mall the box test you have the
controls to see how long they would be
in the lit area and so for the controls
they were in there for about 150 seconds
while the antibiotic trees is once
stayed in the light areas a little bit
more about 225 seconds or so so again
similar results in that or a different
way to test similar results that the
microbiome might be influencing our
behavior making us less anxious what's
more is they decide to take these
antibiotics and then let them recolonize
they're by bacteria normally after two
weeks and so then they subjected them to
the same test and to see how they would
do and those results are in these
grayish bars over here and as you can
see they have partially or almost
completely restored the behavior - which
would be considered normal for for these
mice so again suggesting that there
might be some interaction between our
micro gut microbiota and behavioural
changes
so another concept that I'd like to
bring up and might help with the next
case in the concept of germ-free mice
and specific pathogen free mice and so
germ-free mice as you might guess are
mice that or animals that don't have any
germs or bacteria so they have to live
in a very sterile environment and eats
their own food meanwhile for the
specific pathogen free mice or animals
these guys will have specific bacteria
which they would be screened for so that
at least there would be a limited or
somewhat known set of bacterium which
they don't have which can help for
certain studies additionally another
concept that will come up is this
concept of a microbial a gut transplant
or in my as a microbiota fecal
transplant and so what this will do is a
procedure in which you'll take the
sequel or stools
I guess result samples from an
individual and then you'll transfer it
into another person or animal and you
can do this either orally with some
pills or you can do it the other way
with an enema and so in this experiment
they want to make use of the step-down
anxiety test and what they want to do
here which is really cool is they want
to make use of the behavioral
differences in two strains of mice
solicit we did about sea mice which is
known to be a little bit more timid and
more anxious than the other mice which
is the NIH Swiss mice and so here we
have where they had each of these
strains being germ-free and then
subjected them to this anxiety test then
they had another group of these same
mice but then had the microbiome of the
other strain of mice being transplanted
into them and then see how well they
performed in these anxiety tests
and so focusing on the left part we have
the NIH Swift mice and so I've mentioned
that the NIH Swiss mice they are a
little bit more exploratory and less
timid than the belt sea mice so they're
time to step down from this pedestal or
this platform about 20 seconds meanwhile
meanwhile when you incorporate the
microbiota from the other strain the
time in which it takes them to step down
from this platform increases in to about
60 seconds similarly in the galaxy mice
they would take or they're again known
to be more timid more anxious so as
expected with the normal I guess SBS and
the germ-free mice they would take quite
a bit of time to step down of about
jointed 80 seconds which is quite a bit
more than the NI NH Swiss mice however
when you subjected them to a fecal
transplant with the other strain the
time in which they took to step down or
decreased so again this these results
show that or indicate possibly that the
gut microbiota can also influence our
behavior and anxiety and that it can be
transferable
so additionally not only in behavior
this group want to look at brain
chemistry differences until focusing
specifically on the NIH Swiss mice they
after they transplanted the microbiota
of the other strain they waited three
weeks and then they measured the BDNF
levels in the hippocampus and the
amygdala and BDNF is an acronym for
brain derived neurotrophic factor and is
known to be a neuro protective and
neurogenesis factor in the brain and so
when you subject them to be the other
kind of microbiota from the different
strain you can see some differences at
least in the hippocampus in terms of how
much the NF factor is being generated of
course in the amygdala you can see here
that there wasn't any change so even
though there was any change in the
amygdala there was at least some
measurable difference in the hippocampus
so just think not only that the
microbiome might have some behavioral
influences on on the on the rat on mice
but also a chemical change as well so in
another study they did a similar
experiment looking at the at least one
of the experiments they want to look at
the light dark box ma
test as well and this time comparing the
germ-free and specific pathogen free
mice and so from here and see that the
specific pathogen free mice want to
spend more time in the dark areas so
they were all more timid or more anxious
however once you get rid of their
microbiota for the germ-free mice and
see that their time in the light area
increased significantly and suggesting
that there might be some connection
between a gut microbiota and our
behavior
so another test they did that they did
was called the open field test of
anxiety so again we have a box but this
time there's no platform or anything so
now what you want to concentrate on is
either the center of the open area and
then the walled area and so this again
is a test or anxiety because the mice
might want to or the animals might want
to stay more closely to the walls rather
than the open areas so for this test you
want to see how willing these animals
are to spend their time in this unknown
open area so what this group did is they
want to look at a possible developmental
dependence of the gut microbiome and so
what they have there are three groups of
mice or yes so they have germ-free mice
they have a specific pathogen free mice
and then there were they have what's
called a conventional mice in which you
start off having a germ-free mice and
then you add in normal bacterial colony
later and so they did it in early life
and also in adult life and what I have
here the results from when they did in
early life so they had mice grew up to a
certain age in the early life and then
they recognized them to be specific
pathogen free and so I mentioned that
this is a using the open field test and
one way to quantify anxiety is what's
called the number of reuse that they
have or the number of times in which
they stand on their hind legs which is
an indication that they might be more
open to the idea to explore things and
less anxious and so I want to point out
here to the the white dots here and then
the black dots so the white or the
specific pathogen for you the ones that
have some sort of bacteria in them all
the black dots are the ones there
germ-free
and so the gray dots here the ones that
are conventionalized
in young early life and so you can see
that after you conventionalized them a
little bit it partially restores their
behavior towards what would be
considered normal in this case again
suggesting that there is some influence
on the microbiota and even developmental
changes in our brain so again they did
this also in the adult life so these are
mice were grown up to be germ free until
their adult life and then they were
conventionalized with some microbiota or
some bacteria so unfortunately here we
see that there is no change between the
ones our germ-free and the ones that
were colonized in adulthood so again
this both of these suggests that there
is some window in which that our
microbiome might be important in correct
brain development and normal behavior so
the last study that I'll focus on is
turning into more depression so in the
previous studies we're focusing on
anxiety and so what this group did is
firstly they want to look at what the
compositional differences in the gut
microbiota in patients with depression
and healthy controls and to look at
compositional changes there's two
metrics at least to look at which are
called a richness and diversity and so
richness is simply just a number of
different species or groups in the
sample while diversity takes an account
not only the number of different species
but also their abundances as well and so
comparing both the controls and to their
depression counterparts you can see that
the depression patients had less less a
number of different groups
and also less diversity in their guts so
again suggesting that at least in
depression there's also some change that
happens that might be associated with
depression so not only that so they
focus solely on humans first but then
they want to try out if they can even
replicate that depressive phenotype into
rats as well and so for rats they start
off with a normal rat and then so they
grow they raise them into a certain age
so they can develop normally with
bacteria and then they'll subject them
to four weeks of antibiotics trying to
wipe out their entire microbiome or
their microbiota and then they'll
subject them to a fecal transplant from
those depressed patients then they'll
try some behavioral tests to see if they
can recapitulate those kind of
depressive phenotypes in these rats and
so one test of depression in animal
animal models is to see their preference
to sucrose and so excuse me so when both
of them the control mice and the equally
transplanted mice were subject to this
sucrose preference test the depressive
mice now prefer the sucrose less so than
their control counterparts so suggesting
that there is a transfer of this
depressive phenotype to not like certain
things anymore similar to in maybe a
human additionally they did a open field
test and again they had this this box
they're just a wide open field in the
places of interest are the center open
area and then the wall and so here they
found that the controls would be in the
center for about 15 to 20 seconds
meanwhile
the press mice and now I guess you can
consider the press mice or rats they
only see in the senator for about five
seconds so again trying to relay the
behavioral phenotype interview threat so
you just sing a strong influence on the
gut microbiota in depression
so in summary of these cases so far that
we've seen a connection between the a
gut related disorder IBS and anxiety and
depression so some connection there
along with the contamination of the
drinking water and then we looked at
some studies that try to recapitulate or
a look at the effects of the microbiota
in anxiety and development and last we
just covered going into depression and
how it's related or possibly suggest to
be associated with depression and
changes in the microbiota so now I'd
like to switch into some areas that
might be interesting to go in from here
namely some network methods some
neuroimaging looking at multiple body
sites and then I'll end with talking
about concept those hallmarks of this
axis so talking about the ecological and
Network methods of cellular biome or the
microbiota so scientist so far has maybe
looked at the microbiome or P Racal
sense where they would add in maybe one
to a couple of these certain bacteria so
they can study it in animal models
however you know that the microbio has
so many different species that you can't
keep on doing this empirically and at
some point you have to look at all of
them together and all these interactions
together in some and possibly a network
model and this is powerful in order to
capture all these different interactions
that might happen between a group or a
certain subset of
the bacteria additionally there might be
some Network signatures once you take an
account all these bacteria some Network
signatures that might help in predicting
certain diseases so there's this one
group that tried to make use of the
microbiota in a more clinically
diagnosed or to clinically diagnosed
Crohn's disease and so they want to see
if adding in information about the
network of these interactions of the
bacteria can better diagnose or predict
Crohn's disease better than just
clinical features alone and so they rip
to find that and give some hope for
network models to help predict disease
additionally you can go for a more
ecology method and looking at the
microbiome over time and how it deals
with certain changes or perturbations to
it and so one example of how the
microbiome might initially become stable
and be okay and then fall into some sort
of unstable Nisour a disease state is
Clostridium disappear this is a few he
did in other words and so this
introduction into your gut can wreak
havoc on your gut system and provides a
example of this kind of model where
initially your gut is normal and then
some change the C this is introduced and
there's a great change and unstability
in which it propagates to the whole
digestive tract and so network models
and using ecology is very powerful
method to studying these interactions
and the gut microbiome
so another method that could be used as
new imaging so I touch briefly on the
chemical differences that the microbiome
might add to or change in our brains so
additional measurement you can do is to
image the brain itself to see what it's
up to
and so one example of this is called
resting state functional MRI in which an
individual or the animal organism would
be in just a resting state not doing
much and will be subjected to an MRI
which would look at the changes in blood
flow in the brain and so an example of
at least the new imaging part being
studying some gut disease here's an
example in which they want to look at
indigestion and possible changes in the
in in the brain and so what they wanted
to do is take healthy controls and
people with indigestion and try to use
machine learning algorithm to try to
differentiate the two and so even though
this model doesn't use the microbiota in
per se one can speculate that adding in
the microbiome could also give you some
extra information to increase the amount
of predictability power that you have in
distinguishing between healthy controls
and some disease State
so another area in which you can make
use of the microbiota is looking at
multiple body sites or different
microbes microbiota and so here of an
example of just this diversity that can
be found on the skin and so you can see
the compositional differences shown in
these small pie charts and you can see
that they all vary across the bio site
based on maybe some dry areas versus
some more oily areas and so one example
of a group making use of this again not
focusing on the gut or the brain but in
this case they looked at pregnancy they
looked at different different parts of
different microbiota such as the fecal
matter the oral cavity of both the adult
and the infant and even comparing all
those you can see so this is a principal
components analysis plot in which it
tries to find separate differences or be
able to plot them in a 3d space and to
visually see that each of these parts
have a distinct area or sort of
signature to them and so what you might
be able to do is along with the network
methods is try to incorporate all or
multiple microbiota to try to get a
larger picture of how maybe a certain
disease State is affecting only just one
ecosystem but another as well and so I
want to wrap up we're talking about this
interesting paper suggesting a sort of
hallmarks of the microbiota gut brain
access and so I'll briefly go over them
the indistinguishability convergent
properties bi-directional by
directionality signaling a critical
development window and their own neural
homeo genesis homeostasis
all right so in distinguishability
is the the concept of that so now we
can't really study the human without
considering the our microbe counterparts
so this was suggested in the human
microbiome project started in 2007 and
we suggested that humans should be
studied as a super organism which again
is the you have to study the human part
but also with the our microbe friends as
well and again suggested in some of the
cases I showed that even in development
or even our normal behavior can be
affected by our microbiota changes so
again thinking about them being as one
and you should be able to study them
together so the concept of emergence is
sort of where as heading with the the
network methods in which can't just
study maybe one two of these bacteria by
themselves but however when they all
come together they come up with certain
emergent properties that might not
otherwise be seen in these individual
bacteria themselves and in terms of
bi-directional signaling I'm going to
touched on at least the bi-directional
signaling and we've got in the brain but
you can also add in the micro
microorganisms in there as well because
they would also interact with the immune
system or just as a review the some of
the interactions between the gut in the
brain of the immune endocrine and neural
connections so for the immune system
they have to deal with what it considers
to be formed and the bacteria are still
considered non-human so they will have
to regularly interact with our
microbiota and they of the sensing
else's brain additionally we have
endocrine signals such as serotonin and
histamine which can be developed or the
byproducts of some certain metabolism of
the bacteria in our gut and lastly the
neural part of it is the bacteria is
being on our gut might send some signals
to our brain and their sends bacteria
such as segmented back
Espio it segmented filamentous bacteria
in which they adhere to the gut itself
and so that can also signal to the brain
as well as some certain things going on
clinical window of Lewy I mentioned this
briefly in one of the cases in trying to
look at the dependence of the microbiota
in development and so this is that again
there's some window possibly that if we
don't develop with our microbiome there
could be some long term effects in terms
of behavior and brain development and
this also makes sense from an
immunological standpoint as well because
as we grow up we'll or from from being
an infant you're exposed to all these
different microbes and you have to be
able to distinguish which one are good
and bad and if you aren't exposed to
these harmless ones then if you're
exposed to later your body will think
that there's some some they might be
pathogenic and you'll have some
overreaction to them and I say I want to
touch on neural home agent or
homeostasis and again touched on the
BDNF factor which is involved in neural
protection and just like keeping a
healthy brain and so again the
microbiome may also be implicated in
keeping a healthy and normal brain state
and behavior so that comes the hallmarks
of the microbiota brain access and that
concludes my presentation so thanks so
much and I'll take some questions yes
so you brought up a lot of rapport the
hallmarks a lot of different approaches
that could be taken when I'm trying to
determine is where you see because it is
in the symposium and one of things we
can do is kind of give you feedback as
you're trying to think about your
proposal sir where is the low-hanging
fruit that you're really because because
what I want to avoid is kind of a
laundry list of here's things that could
be done where do you is the low-hanging
fruit disclosed to something that might
actually really have an implication for
an intervention or implications for
health yeah so in the the depression
case I saw I shared they did a multitude
of other tests as well so they not only
looked at the the diversity and richest
I mentioned but they also looked at
cytokines and stuff like that but their
analysis they only looked at maybe
certain differences in certain microbes
so they didn't take into account maybe
certain like low abundance microbes that
might influence those more highly
abundant ones so I feel like maybe more
network methods could be a low-hanging
fruit in that yeah
I'm against it
okay so how would you how would you
identify yeah um so I haven't studied
emerging properties intensely but I
would guess you could try to find if you
had a be able to look at the microbes
themselves maybe get a subset of them
that might be highly characterized and
trying to I mean I guess one property
that you could think about is the their
metabolic output so the byproducts in
which they have in terms of just them
living and if you have say focus on some
smaller subset and you can know what
they output and maybe in when you put
them all together you can also measure
their output and see if maybe I mean a
very naive way but see if their output
is what it would be expected if they
were all just individual and independent
from each other and so you might be able
to compare those differences but I'm
sure there are more sophisticated
methods to identify emergent properties
yes yeah this this may actually be a
little brief raising of Shannon's
question that I understand and you know
the biology is really interesting I'm
trying to trying to get trying to kind
of get an understanding of what what
aspects of bioinformatics would really
address some of these problems
critically yeah you know so how what
kinds of tools or techniques really what
kinds of questions are you going to
address that would be amenable to the
kinds of you know approaches we apply to
various kinds of data that would come
out of this and
so one way it would be kind of like the
example I showed in trying to
differentiate between like a healthy
state and a diseased state using certain
machine learning algorithms and so that
would make they would take into more of
a sophisticated view and kind of
differentiating what kind of bacteria
are in one state or another because
maybe a naive way to look has maybe look
at maybe the top five bacteria that
might be in each of them and try to
compare those and that might not be
enough so it could use to make use of
all of them and see if there's also
maybe some differences between the two
to help with I guess see the diagnosis
of prediction of this disease yeah
get at the square
I mean that's an area that could look
into one way would be to maybe because
sometimes you not might not be able to
measure those rare microbes and they're
so similar to those rare gene expression
in like humans and so maybe you couldn't
possibly impute the data as one way to
look at it some if if you knew April is
that they might be there from other
studies so I might be a way to get that
trying to get those little one in one
but
wait
yeah
what if exchange
all right to look at those low abundance
ones yeah Isaiah that's also a
possibility that the low abundant ones
might be the most important ones again
similar to like gene expression
study
I'm tsunami Oh more of a intervention to
do okay
I do not know right now but good book so
that paper that on depression that was
published last year so I mean within
that year there might have been
so in terms of data of signing on maybe
make use of Lisa's data and so she has a
cohort of individuals that have some
swings aiya tea or depression and also
some samples from from their stool so in
terms of the other content sets I might
be able to look at I'm still collecting
and seeing what else there is out there
cool and all other questions
all right well thanks so much for
stopping by
[Applause]